so continuing our weekly series on
omega-level Newtons in this video I want
to shift our focus to one of the most
powerful mutants in the history of
Marvel Comics none other than Santa
Claus
however because he only appears within
the main Marvel continuity once with a 6
page short story instead of focusing
strictly on his powers I want to beef
this up a bit
by providing you guys with a story
itself and then wrapping back around as
to why he's considered to be an
omega-level mutant so coming after the
departure of Chris Claremont and Jim Lee
from the x-men title the establishment
of Santa as a mutant came as part of
both the x-man's and a joking desire to
explain how Santa was capable of
achieving the various feats associated
with his historical acts to expand on
this during the 80s and 90s the x-men
were Marvel's top 2 your team and their
highest selling publication the reason
why is that for every instance of a
Phoenix saga or sentinel attack there
were stories that also included
light-hearted comedic moments in order
to keep the series fresh and interesting
for existing and prospective readers
continuing this theme after Claremont
left the series within the same year in
1991 Scott Liddell contributed a 6 page
short story containing Santa Claus for
Marvel's annual holiday special picking
up with the x-men of storm Banshee
Nightcrawler Wolverine and Colossus
decorating the Christmas tree and the
mists of their celebrations they're met
with an alarm from cerebro informing
them that it has detected the most
powerful mutant ever registered now
something to point out here is a common
misconception held by fans who have read
this comic this alert from cerebro is
meant to indicate that the mutant
detected is the most powerful mutant
ever registered up to this point in time
not in the overall history of Marvel
Comics now because the Charter of the
x-men is to investigate all newly
detected mutants and offered them a
place within their ranks the x-men
depart for Rockefeller Center to locate
the mutant in question shifting our
focus to Rockefeller Center itself we
actually join up with a third iteration
of the Brotherhood of Evil Mutants
itself led by toad and consisting of The
Blob who have superhuman strength and
near impenetrable skin pyro who could
control fire but could not actually
create it mastermind who can manipulate
the five senses of the human body to
create illusions Eunice the untouchable
who could generate a force field of
energy around himself in Fantasia who
had the power to sense and manipulate
electronic signals with the x-men
appearing in the same location
the store reveals that the Brotherhood
of Evil Mutants had detected the same
signal as the x-men leading both groups
to the same location while the events
turned out to be rather predictable and
that the x-men confront the Brotherhood
with the two doing battle against one
another in the midst of their conflict
Santa makes his appearance known by
ending the fight and re materializing
the Brotherhood of Evil Mutants into
action figures coming to the conclusion
the Santa Clause is a mutant that had
been detected by cerebro instead of
being able to induct him into their
ranks
Santa actually teleports the x-men away
with no memories of cerebro's mutant
discovery their battle with the
Brotherhood and their discovery that
Santa himself is a mutant now wrapping
this up into his powers and what defines
him as an omega-level mutant because
this is the one true Santa Claus of
Christmas legend within Marvel Comics
the real world stories of Santa flying a
sleigh giving presents sliding down
chimneys without being burned and
traveling around the world in one night
we're all folded in as aspects of his
powers to this end as a mutant of Marvel
Comics Santa has the following abilities
immortality telepathy telekinesis
teleportation weather manipulation on a
global scale matter and molecular
manipulation immunity to cold and heat
and gravity manipulation what this means
is that a Santa Claus had a bad day he
could quite literally wipe out all life
on the planet earth or simply
materialize a planet earth into
something else entirely
we don't really know but I don't think
we want to find out but without being
said we're going to bring this video to
an end I know it was short but I hope
you guys enjoyed it because that is
actually a pretty powerful character but
if you guys are interested in learning
more about the different versions of
Santa Claus in Marvel Comics the
Asgardian version and the version that
apparently helps fight elves and even
the version that had the infinity-combo
for a while then feel free to post a
comment below let me know and I will
catch you guys later peace